gesture of defiance through the center
of key
a city that Moscow had intended to
capture within a few days a parade of
destroyed Russian tanks one and a half
years after the full-scale invasion of
Ukraine
this is the second Independence Day
celebrated here since the start of this
War
I feel a great pride for my country for
my people and most of all Farrow Armed
Forces who are defending us
as a soldier I feel the pain of losing
so many of our guys
I'm grateful to our Warriors and heroes
which include my husband who has not
returned from captivity
like last year there are no large-scale
events for fear of a Russian attack to
coincide with the holiday that could
produce Mass casualties
overnight a missile landed in a
neighborhood in the eastern city of
dinipro injuring nearly a dozen people
but at about the same time Ukrainian
Special Forces made an amphibious
assault on russian-controlled Crimea
briefly unfurling once more the national
flag
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
has promised this week that Crimea will
one day be quote deoccupied
he delivered a video message to Mark
Independence Day
is
a holiday of Free People of strong
people of people with dignity of equals
Ukrainian men and women all of them in
our entire country today we celebrate
the 32nd anniversary of Ukrainian
Independence this is a value of each of
us and this is what we are fighting for
after 18 months with war raging just as
fiercely as when it began for most
ukrainians Independence is the freedom
that neighboring Russia seems intent on
denying them making them ever more
determined to preserve it at all costs
Rob McBride Al Jazeera Keith
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera